you wrote in the book that playing
professional football is like getting in
a car crash
every Sunday yeah do you worry about
concussions I don't worry about him no I
mean I'm not oblivious to him I mean I
understand the risks that you know come
with the contact sports and the physical
nature of our game I try to take these
preventive approaches to limit you know
whatever ramifications those may cause
now do I have it all the answers for
those absolutely not I don't think
anyone does but if I take this proactive
approach to it I do feel like you know
all these other treatments that I've
done on my body have really worked and I
do want to continue to think about my
head the same way so I do focus on a lot
of treatment for my head neck certainly
for my shoulders along with the rest of
my body in order to try to absorb those
forces I'm gonna face you know in a much
better way and I'll tell you why because
when you're an athlete and again I've
looked around in a locker room for a
long period of time and you know I read
everything like everybody else you know
I see what athletes of the past what
their future looks like you know and you
try to learn from those things and you
know you try to be some of my idols had
to retire because of head injuries so I
thought how can you start thinking about
head injuries in a preventative way if I
still am gonna play the sport that I
love and you know that's what I've tried
to think about I mean do you think the
style the studies that have come out
about concussions affects the future of
the NFL I don't know I mean who knows I
don't know what the future is gonna look
like you know and I'm not gonna pretend
to predict it but I mean football is an
incredible game
I mean it's requires you know so much
discipline and are there things that
come with football that yeah you'd
rather not experience of course but
that's life I mean there's negatives to
skiing you know there's negatives to you
know doing a lot of really great
activities but you know are you not
gonna try anything in life because you
know of the downside or are you gonna
say okay well I understand my wrists but
their rewards far outweigh you know what
the risks may be and I think for me
playing sports because I enjoy them so
much yeah I'm conscious of it but I also
love the sports so much I want to keep
playing and I'm gonna do everything I
can to take care of my body and it
and said the you know the hit said I'm
gonna take on Sunday there are many
analysts that say you are the greatest
quarterback of all time how do you rank
yourself I'm not good with you know
things like that so I I mean I feel like
I've done a great job to maximize what
my potential was there were some
incredible players there so they're guys
I could do things that I could never do
you know how they move in the pocket and
how they escape and you know the way
they play I mean I play with you know
the best coach you know of all time I
mean that's pretty lucky for any player
I played with some incredible players
over the course of my career that have
come together you know to form this
great team and all those players and
there's too many to mention but I play
with this offensive line that always you
know has protected me and there's sole
responsibility for the entire course my
career has been to protect me so are
there a lot of other players that I feel
that if they were in my position knowing
all the things that I've known could
accomplish similar things absolutely I
absolutely do and I feel like I'm very
blessed to be the one that got to do
those things